hi i'm reza aslan and i'm rayne wilson
and i'm dying oh my oh no yeah what
what's going on reza
i don't want to have a very serious
conversation with you
i'm dying
dude i'm
i'm sorry to hear that and so are you
what and so are you and you and you and
you i'm pointing to all the listeners
out there because we are all going to
die that is maybe the one thing we know
we all have in common as human beings i
mean do we really have to talk about
this honestly
this is the most important conversation
you can have and this is only one part
of it we're talking about the fear
of death
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
are you are you afraid are you afraid to
die are you afraid of death i should say
you know i like to think
that i am not
afraid of death but i haven't really
been faced with it and i haven't had to
go through the death of a loved one
so
it's easy for me to say
oh i don't really have a problem with it
it's a part of life
i can tell you that when
you know our elderly dog just died last
month and her everything was failing and
her kidneys were failing and her she
could barely stand up and her quality of
life was sinking rapidly we had a
veterinarian come to the house and give
her a shot so that she passed in our
front yard and we wrote poems to her and
we sat with her in her favorite spot and
we said prayers and we meditated and we
were in nature as she went from
whatever
her doggy consciousness went from this
world to wherever doggy consciousnesses
go the happy hunting grounds and i you
know i was sad and i cried a little bit
but um some people get so caught up in
the death of their animals i mean just
uh just total grief you know it's funny
like i've
most of my life i haven't been afraid of
death at all uh you know for a large
part of my life you know high school and
uh when i was a kid i i was religious
and so
i far from being afraid of death you
know i welcomed it i was like come death
come and i shall have
the true life which awaits me that
sounds shakespeare on the other side um
and then and then after i stopped being
religious i still wasn't all that afraid
of death because i was like well look i
mean this is the life that you have and
then it ends and
worst case scenario you become nothing
and so there's nothing to worry about
anyway
and best case scenario you join nature
you become one with the universe and
that sounds nice
and i'll tell you what changed
is that i had kids
oh and suddenly
out of the blue
i became scared to death of death
like i remember very clearly being on an
airplane once and there was some sort
like serious turbulence
and in the past you know when that
happened i would think to myself well
you know we go down we go down that's a
bummer but it is what it is right
also what a way to go what a way to go i
was thinking about like a plane crash
that's not bad it's kind of cool you've
got like two minutes of hell like
yeah and then boom it's a fireball it's
actually yeah there are you know
definitely worse ways less dramatic ways
to go but i i remember very clearly and
i think my boys were just my twins had
just been born
is that
the plane started shaking
and i freaked the [ __ ] out in a way that
wow in a way that i never had before
yeah and i was like my heart was racing
i was scared
i was so scared that i was gonna die and
i was like what is this i've never had
this feeling before
and i realized
because of my kids
because i have kids now and suddenly i'm
scared of death
and and so here's here's what i find
fascinating is that
i would say that that experience is
shared by the vast majority of us like a
just an
overwhelming fear of death you know we
don't want to talk about it we don't
want to face it we don't we don't want
it in our house or in our lives we want
to sort of turn away from it
and yet
you said it right it's like we're all
we're all dying we're all gonna die yep
can it can't ignore it we let's not be
in denial anymore now we have this guest
this incredible woman her name is uh a
lua arthur yep and she calls herself a
death doula my name is eilua arthur and
i'm a death doula
i
help people with all of the emotional
practical and legal aspects of preparing
for and transitioning through death
so if you're someone like me
who
not so much afraid of death but just
refuse to even think about it at this
point
uh this is the episode for you so we're
going to talk a little bit with a lua
she is the founder of going with grace
which supports people through the whole
process of dying and and then she also
trains other death doulas across the
globe she's uh you know she's on this
mission to to get all of us to face
this uh this gigantic fear of death
can't wait
[Music]
i got into this really serendipitously i
met a woman on a bus in cuba that had
uterine cancer and she was just a couple
years older than i was and during that
bus ride i asked her a lot of questions
about life and about death and what her
death would mean i had her look at her
body in the grave don't ask me why i
thought that was okay to do to a freak
stranger but i did
and we had a really rich conversation
next to you
on any kind of transportation you really
don't want to be next to me on a flight
yeah yeah
and
i started realizing that
you know we're all gonna die right but
we're not talking about it like this was
the first conversation i'd had with
somebody a serious conversation about
mortality about what her life meant
about what her death would mean and i
hadn't asked myself those questions ever
i was a philosophy minor in college but
it still never really come up for me
about me personally theoretically i'd
had the conversation plenty but i never
thought about my own life and death
and so we had this wonderful 14-hour bus
ride and then at the end of it i well
somewhere in the middle i felt very
strongly that i wanted to help people
prepare themselves for dying because
even though she had this very serious
illness she didn't have the proper
support through her medical team she had
a psychiatrist in her oncology program
but he was talking to her about living
with disease
they were not talking about the
possibility of dying from this disease
and that to me felt like a huge failing
and she was opening up and i get that
there are ways that you can engage with
strangers on buses in foreign countries
without bringing up their dead bodies
yes
there are there are those ways
absolutely not my way yeah we went
straight for it we totally went for it
it was beautiful and that conversation
really shifted the trajectory of her
life and ultimately her disease she's
still living and also shifted mine
because i i practiced law beforehand i
was working at the legal aid doing
non-profit work and then
i was
sick i had a deep depression and on this
bus ride things finally started to click
for me and i was like oh
okay there's another way to do society
there's also another way to do my life
wow yeah and the other way to do my life
is to live in consistent relationship
with my death because that creates
possibility for looking at the meaning
of my one unique singular life i i don't
have i don't know what's on the other
side if there is i have ideas i have
really strong beliefs myself i don't
know
but what i can experience right now i
have some evidence for
this i can do this while i'm here i find
myself often on the life side of death
because for me it's an opportunity to
look at living and what comes afterward
if anything i don't know so you're
talking about just living as present and
as deeply and fully as you possibly can
every day
and that i think in and of itself is a
spiritual practice one of the things
that's really
um
just really kind of blew my mind is this
well into
the 20th century
funerals took place in the home right
which means that you would often
live with the dead body
of you know some family member like it
would be in the living room for a while
you know until finally it was taken away
and buried and so there was something
normalizing about the idea of being in
the presence of a dead person
and then of course what's taken over is
this massive death industry right the
purpose of which
is to sanitize the whole thing right
like let's let's take the dead person
out of your sight you don't even have to
worry about and you know what else we're
going to like inject them yeah we're
going to like remove chemicals
their fluids and replace it with
chemicals and we're gonna like put
makeup on we're gonna make them look
like they're not dead and then we're
gonna give you you know 30 minutes
uh in this safe space to kind of look
upon this dead body as though we're
still alive so that we can remove the
the remove you from death and then what
that has done
and the stats are there to to prove it
stats that i'm not going to actually
cite so you just take my word for it god
damn it um
is that we have become more afraid of
death i'm gonna cite these stats
according to chapman university's 2018
survey of american fears
56.4 that's very exact of americans are
afraid or very afraid of people i love
dying and that's up from 38
in 2016.
nearly 20 jump you have interfaced
very much with this fear of death and
the death industry
uh tell us more about that so for
starters i'm always cautioned against
using the term funeral industry
because it makes it sound like this
industrial complex and are coming for us
in my experience it is very much an
industry i mean we can take all the
power out of the word but it did swoop
in and shift how we die and how we
relate to death and dying tremendously
in the past 100 years
i think that the way that we do it now
does not allow us to interface with
dying at all
because the death happens within half an
hour or so maybe an hour if there's
traffic
it somebody comes in and takes the body
away and we don't have an opportunity to
be with it and to understand like to see
this body
as
just a vessel
because once you watch life leave a body
thing start to change not immediately
but there is some perceptible
differences after a while and being with
the body of somebody that you love after
their death i think creates time and
space for us to start to process and
start to reconcile the fact that life
has left but when the body's just taken
away then it's kind of confusing it's an
intellectual exercise right you you know
that something has happened yeah and
then your grief starts as a result of
this intellect rather than being able to
watch the process happen
one of the practices that we do
is we support families in caring for
bodies at home so washing the body after
the death has occurred dressing it
preparing it for whatever's coming next
either getting buried or cremated
and i find that when we involve family
members in the process it really it
gives them a chance to
to care for somebody that they loved one
last time
and to
start to see the color leave their hands
start to watch the cheeks sink in and
start to
really come to terms
with the fact that
life is left the death has occurred i've
only seen one dead body up close and
that was my wife's grandmother
and she was unfortunately like embalmed
in all the traditional kind of methodist
mid-american white suburban ways and
but it was a very uh powerful
experience to be next to her
dead body and to you used the word
vessel i
was really struck by the fact that oh
her name was alice and it's like that's
not alice i was looking at this body was
like that's not alice
that is
a vase
that is a vessel
um that's not that's not her it's just
there's something else that was
ineffably alice
in her being alive
that's just not there now i might be
colored or prejudiced by certain you
know belief systems that i have but i
was just it was kind of meat and
potatoes there was nothing kind of
mystical about it like oh that's not her
that's just a that's just a fleshy thing
that doesn't work anymore i've heard
that experience from across faith
traditions
people looking at a dead body and saying
wait a minute that's not my dad
have you studied death from a lot of
different cultures i'm just wondering
like what modern americans can learn
from indigenous cultures or ancient
cultures about death that would help us
be better at dying i mean reza brought
up the fact that it's really only been
in the last 60 years that we've been
pickling dead bodies i mean we had dead
bodies in the backyard and in our living
rooms and we bathed them and we
you know when you
the reason that people had 12 kids is
because they were sure that six or eight
of them were going to be dying in the
first year of life as you can see in my
tradition both uh the islamic tradition
and the sort of traditional iranian
tradition so the islamic tradition yeah
the body dies and immediately the family
washes it rapid wraps it in a cloth and
just puts it in the ground you know no
like fourteen thousand dollar
gold-plated you know silk lined coffin
just get that body in the ground as fast
as possible
in the sort of uh
ancient iranian tradition so-called
zoroastrian
bodies no they leave them out for the
vultures that's right you just leave the
body out on a hill somewhere so that the
vultures and the
the dogs can come and eat it and it
immediately joins the the
biosphere you know back to the earth but
anyways get back back to the question
what in your study of death what can we
learn as modern americans all of this
that hey there's so many ways to do it
and that our way that we start to
believe is the way
is not the only way that we can approach
it from so many different perspectives
since all the traditions really differ
and
well they all differ but i think
underneath most of them is that the body
is a vessel and it can give back if we
allow it to and also we get to take time
to be with the body if we choose
um culturally that's what the states i
think really has an opportunity to work
with this like rampant death denial is
very sad
and
what we can learn from other cultures is
it's as much a part of living as
breathing is as growing fingernails is
well let's get deep then what is in your
view the difference between living and
dying oh i think they're the opposite
sides of the same coin
i don't think they're all that different
i just think that we have context for
one
we don't have much context for the other
well that's a good answer
ladies and gentlemen if you know
anything about me
you know that uh i like the game of
tennis i like to play tennis i like to
stay hydrated during tennis i need to
keep my energy up sometimes i'm playing
two three hour matches liquid iv helps
me jump start my game it clears my head
space gives me energy you hydrate faster
it's more efficient it contains five
essential vitamins more vitamin c than
an orange did you know that more vitamin
c than an orange more potassium than a
banana it's healthier than sugary sports
drinks has no artificial flavors or
preservatives less sugar than an apple
it's made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan free of dairy gluten and soy it is
on a mission to change the world also
the company is donating 4 million
servings in response to covet 19 their
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military liquid iv has donated
over 11 million servings globally so
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
you can go to costco that's one way to
do it or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquidive.com and you use the code
milkshake at checkout that's 25
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code
milkshake at liquidive.com folks when it
comes to saving time and working more
efficiently it's the little things that
start adding up and hogging time in your
day grammarly premium gives you real
time suggestions on your writing so you
can get to the next item on your list in
record time and listen i know a lot of
you out there are like grammar i mean
what is this
the difference between somebody taking
you seriously and somebody not taking
you seriously is grammar and with
grammarly you can get things like
clarity suggestions it'll help you get
your message across quickly without
repeated or unnecessary words you can
get vocabulary suggestions so like no
more searching for synonyms you teach
reza do you suggest to your students
that they use uh grammarly oh yeah
grammar is about communication it's
about how you you communicate yourself
your thoughts your ideas even with the
free version of grammarly you can be
safe from embarrassing basic spelling
mistakes or or punctuation mistakes but
grammarly's premium version
that has all these time saving features
that help you write more clearly and
efficiently you can streamline your
workload with seamless integration into
microsoft office your internet browser
your phone more you don't have to
embarrass yourself with like silly
grammar mistakes when you're sending out
emails anymore hit send with confidence
get your point across more effectively
with grammarly premium get twenty
percent off grammarly premium by signing
up at grammarly.com milkshake that's
twenty percent off at grammarly g r a
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y dot com slash
milkshake
i have a question
amy yeah
thank you if if dying is a part of
life two sides of the same coin are are
we just all dying right now
i think are we just all sitting here
dying and having this conversation kinda
you know i always ask people when do we
begin to die
and nobody has a solid answer some say
when we're born but then the new cells
are being made some say
when you are
in recognition of the fact one day
you're gonna die when you have a
terminal illness and i use air quotes
around the word terminal because we're
all terminal when do we begin to die i
can tell you
tell me 53. what happened then
that's where i'm starting to die that's
where i that's first of all let me just
say what a brilliant business plan
this is because it's like well we're all
dying right like right now you are dying
so therefore call the death doula
now
yeah well i work with healthy people too
i should say yeah
yeah tell me about like if a healthy
person calls you and is like i'm fine
i'm not you know i'm fine but i would
like make an end-of-life plan a
middle-aged couple or something like
that many of my clients are a
53-year-old actor
podcast children you make a solid
end-of-life plan write down all the
practical things and through that almost
always gets to the emotional and the
spiritual just by getting really clear
on who you want to make your decisions
for you when you can what you think
about life support what it actually
means for you how you want to be cared
for what you want done with your body
what about your possessions do you have
any sacred sentimental possessions what
are the stories behind them would you
want to enjoy these things after you die
what's going to happen to your wedding
ring
what are you going to do with your pets
if you have any
all your important information your
passwords where's your birth certificate
the title for your car
and then a life review look at the thing
the meaning that your life has had
things that you want to pass on or say
or do or
things that you want to you want to say
i'm sorry to somebody that you never did
throughout history
um you wrote about this in your book
about god reza about
the one of the evidences of the the
spiritual impulse of humanity is the
fact that people have always been buried
with their stuff as if they are going on
a journey
um they're buried with a sword or
they're buried with their pet dog or
you know a brooch or a map or a paddle
like they're gonna row somewhere what
would we all like to be buried with
um
i would like to be married with my
science fiction book collection from the
1970s you were such a nerd
you are such a nurse i'm not laughing at
the suggestion it's a great thing i'm
watching him calling you a nerd that's
awesome that's true i fully embrace it
so does that mean you can visit asimov
and michael morcock and
we're gonna all go on this ride together
so you don't want anybody else to enjoy
those things after you can't
you
i don't want to be buried with anything
because i don't want to be buried i just
uh what do you want i don't know i you
know
or if i am going to be buried i'd like
it very much sort of in that islamic
tradition of just sort of
put me directly in the ground and let me
just kind of feed the earth not be this
poisoned vessel inside of a sealed box
that will take up space for eternity and
he won't decompose
god that's terrible so i was reading
that monarch butterflies last year went
down by 84 in the state of california so
i would like to be buried under milkweed
thistles
that feed the monarch butterflies and
allow them to reproduce so that my body
is part of the natural cycle of things
you said like you would you had said
something once to the effect of
what you do basically is that you help
people who are close to death whatever
that means
um
on what it looks like which i think is
so fascinating like what does death look
like
it's a really good question because none
of us actually really know right
it's such a
it's a hard concept to get your head
around what your ideal death would be
because it's such an unideal situation
for most of us and so i try to help
people get comfortable with the idea of
the deathbed and craft it the way that
they'd like would you like to die at
home would you prefer to be in a
hospital do you want to be surrounded by
people do you want to be alone do you
want your dogs in the bed what does your
deathbed look like even though you might
not really want to think oh my god that
is the greatest question i've ever heard
in my life it's the rich one what is
going to be part of our our uh final
questions like yeah what does your
deathbed what does your deathbed look
like amy my death bed
is enormous it's like a california king
california king you live in new york
city it should only be a single
it will be my deathbed will be the size
of my entire home by the time we get to
that point
just like a mattress on the floor and
it will be covered in crisp white linens
and
all members of my family will be in bed
with me and we'll all somehow find some
way to spoon
there won't be any animals i don't think
so i gotta i gotta be honest like i'm i
was sitting here and i was i assumed
that eventually somebody would ask me
that question what does your deathbed
look like and i was kind of sitting here
thinking about how to answer that and
like and the first thing that comes to
my mind is yes of course my entire
family and my wife and my kids and all
this stuff and then suddenly i had to
pause
and
sort of confront something and it just
suddenly occurred to me that
you know if i am let's say i'm dying
from some degenerate disease
i don't
know if i
want my sons
to see me that way look i'm going to get
a little bit personal here i usually
don't talk about this but not that long
ago my dad died
and i still haven't had to figure out a
way to kind of
kind of understand how to how to process
that whole thing but
when i think of my dad now i always
think of him
as this kind of weak
sick
bag of bones
on a deathbed and i can't get past that
image and so suddenly i'm thinking
well maybe i don't want that kind of
deathbed all of a sudden
[ __ ] i have a question to ask you yeah
what did your dad teach you about dying
through the way that he did it
i i i wish the answer was going to be
like
positive and enlightening but get real
reza the truth is i think the answer is
how not to die
juicy so as a father
well i think as a parent a big part of
your
mission i don't have children is to show
kids well at least to give them enough
space to figure out how to do this earth
on their own right and so your father in
his dying was still doing the thing for
you by showing you how not to do it
either we're showing people how to get
it done or how not to do
[Music]
it i ask you know you talk to and see so
many people right when they're when
they're truly facing death like staring
death right in the face are there
patterns and
and how what people are seeing or
hearing
are people all talking about the same
thing
no not overall but i will say something
that comes up more than any other
is this internal knowledge that death is
coming
i think a lot of people that come to me
have to have some awareness that they're
gonna die right but for a lot of people
that have a serious illness and it looks
like treatment isn't working anymore
maybe they've been on hospice
even though it is an intellectual
knowing that death is coming i think
there's also it's coupled with an
internal one quiet moment yeah i'm dying
i had one really interesting case where
the family called me and they wanted me
to come in and talk to their brother who
had i think it was a brain cancer and
they did not want me to say that i was a
death doula they wanted me we came up
with some name like a special disease
interventionist or something so i went
in i talked to them
they asked that i talked to him i was in
the room alone with him for a while and
he said hey
i know that i'm dying but can you please
not tell them
and i thought wow look at that
they had an idea
he knew they weren't talking to each
other everybody's afraid everybody's
afraid and we don't want to make people
uncomfortable by even bringing it up
yeah even though it's happening for all
of us all the time so then how do we
ease that anxiety how do we
address the fear that we all have
of dying i read a really good quote by
khalil gibran yesterday actually posted
it on the internet because that's where
all the good quotes are
uh that said oh god i'm going to mess it
up but the the
point is that our anxiety comes not from
thinking about it but rather our
inability to control it
and so it's about surrender well it's
about talking about it first this really
helps and then it's about surrender
ultimately
once we can get more comfortable the
fact that i can't control when or how
or why even really
um unless i choose my own ending
it all remains a mystery i think you got
the the quote exactly right i just
googled it while you were talking our
anxiety does not come from thinking
about the future but from wanting to
control it yeah so that talks to me
about uh a kind of a brave surrender and
serenity
that we just don't know
and to embrace the not knowing
100 because what else
i can't know
i can't how do you want to die oh gosh
oh i love this um
my final moments
yeah yeah yeah well i'd like to have a
disease
that so i know that my death is coming
any specific disease that you would do
no i know the ones i don't want
right don't want alzheimer's or dementia
brutal
i would like to have some awareness that
my death is approaching
i would like to be in a bed in my own
home or outside on a deck
i want to feel breeze in my hair
i want to see the sun change i like
maybe around sunset to see the colors
change
i wish i could hear some water i want to
hear voices not directly around me i
want to see nature more than anything
but i'd love to know that the people
that i love are nearby
i'd like to
i'd like to really sink into the
gratitude for this really magical
really
juicy life i've lived
and
and surrender to
this next adventure whatever it may be
gracefully
and with some
style yeah
yeah that's beautiful how do you want to
die ring i can i'm just i'm going to
take what she said can i say ditto you
know
true story rain i'm like
almost 50 years old yep i don't have a
doctor what i haven't had a doctor in
like 10 years the other day i asked my
wife i was like shouldn't we have a
doctor what about zocdoc zocdoc tell me
more look you download the free zoc doc
app that's zlcdoc and it's the easiest
way to find a great doctor and instantly
book an appointment reza you don't need
a phone book you don't need to ask your
friends you go to zoc doc you can search
for local doctors who will take your
insurance you can read verified patient
reviews and book an appointment in
person or online a video chat you'll
never have to be on hold with a
receptionist again so whether you need a
primary care physician
dentist dermatologist psychiatrist in
your case psychiatrist would be super
helpful eye doctor or other specialist
zocdoc has you covered wait this is like
basically made for me i mean how weird
is it
that i have to find out about zocdoc in
the middle of reading ad content i'm i'm
i am signing up for zocdoc right now
tell me how to do it okay you're gonna
go to zocdoc.com slash milkshake and
download the zockdoc app to sign up for
free
raza listen every month millions of
people use zuckdoc and i'm one of them
you are going to be one of them as well
it's my go-to whenever i need a doctor
or medical specialists zocdoc makes
healthcare easy now is the time to
prioritize your health go to zocdoc.com
milkshake and download the zocdoc app to
sign up for free and book a top rated
doctor many are available as soon as
today that's
zocdoc.com
milkshake
okay if i'm going to be a hundred
percent honest like obviously i want to
die in old age that would be nice i'd
like to live a very long long long life
i'd like to have you know
my faculties and all that stuff but if
you're asking
how would i like to
die
i'd like to die in a very public
way like maybe maybe saving somebody
else like that's that's how i would like
i would love do you want to be on the 11
o'clock now i want to be on the 11
o'clock news i would actually love to
die i really truly would love to die
at age let's say 90 for lack of a better
number and i'm playing king lear in like
shakespeare in the park at like uh in
san diego and i'm like blow winds and
crack your cheek
and like keel over on the stage standing
ovation in front of a thousand people
standing ovation and they think it's the
performance and then the ambulance comes
and everyone is asked and then the
understudies brought on to finish the
show the show must go on
but uh just from my theater background i
truly there have been a handful of
actors that have died on the stage and
really that's the best way to go
yeah i think about how cool it is that
some people get to die doing the thing
that they love can i notice what the
difference i just realized between the
way rayne and i answer that question and
the way that you answer that question
like your your brain functions
differently because you are constantly
surrounded by death
when reign and i answered that question
what we actually said wasn't how we
wanted to die but how we wanted to be
remembered for dying like it's all about
legacy like we're constantly thinking
about how people think about us and you
were just like well no i just it's about
me it's about me and the sensation so
like is it
how much of is that involved in the idea
of death and dying it's less about like
the journey that you're going on now and
about how other people will think about
that journey will think about you
people do care a lot about legacy and
how they're remembered in their death
but we're leaving a legacy all the time
right the legacy is not optional whether
or not we die on stage or you die a very
quiet death at home it's being written
with every action with every smile at
cvs or not we're writing our legacy how
hard i loved the big things i did yeah
but also
was i an [ __ ]
[Music]
elua before we end uh we do a little
thing called a lightning round life's
big questions lightning round i'm going
to start us off describe your soul in 10
words or less
sunshine golden
turquoise
hot pink
sparkly glitter
that
is specific answer i love it do you pray
no
don't tell my parents
what would you want your final meal to
be
oh well you know i have a perspective on
this because the body stops taking in
food
and stops processing it at some point
so without my doula perspective about
what happens with the body it'd probably
be french fries no we want to hear your
doula perspective okay the doula
perspective is that i will stop eating
probably like three days before my death
altogether because the body can't the
organs are shutting down the digestive
system shuts down and so i don't i don't
want to be taking in food anymore
because it's gonna be too hard for the
body to process but what about like a
taste like a taste of like dark
chocolate just a little maybe a little
bit on the a little bit on the tongue
and then wipe it off
french fries
[Laughter]
when was the last time you ugly cried
oh gosh
joshua tree july
6th specific couple days ago
wow or a couple weeks ago yeah yeah july
6 joshua tree yeah dare i ask
what happened i got my heart broken
earlier this year and i decided i was
finally like putting it all to bed i
decided it was going to be over i'm done
being sad about this
and in the middle of it this bird
popped around and then i looked away and
i looked back and i like flapped a wing
and then it died
i swear to god
so i'm looking at this bird like what is
happening bird why wh what
it was actually dead i carried it over
let it wait for a while to see if it
died proper it had and then i marched it
up into the hills underneath some rocks
and i buried it and then sobbed
there like uglies not
can't see trying to make it back down
the rocks
recognizing at least i felt at the time
that i was burying
this heavy heartbreak and sadness that
i've been carrying around with me for a
while
wow that's what happened and then i
learned that it was a morning dove
m-o-u-r-n-i-n-g
a morning some morning was dying morning
died totally and then i buried it
wow ugly cry
there you have it there you have it well
elua arthur this has been such a so
delightful
fascinating forced us to think life
changing discussion
uh you can be found on
goingwithgrace.com your website right
for those who want to know more and you
actually teach death doula ing i kind of
wanted to do that class do it i kind of
want to do it somebody in your life is
going to die
yeah yeah wait
that sounded weirdly prophetic now i'm a
little freaked out someone in my life is
going to die i mean i immediately went
through that you were like wait a second
this has been an extraordinary
conversation
thank you so much thank you
man that was uh that was deep i'm uh i
feel affected by this episode it was so
strangely intimate isn't it amazing how
when you talk about death in that way
like how intimate uh and personal the
conversation gets instantly yeah i
honestly have never i don't even talk
about my dad's death with my wife and i
just shared it with
that literally dozens of our listeners
well don't dozens is you know hundreds
i think we might be in the hundreds at
this point
metaphysical milkshake listeners viewers
wherever you may be
thanks for tuning in uh we love you so
very much we wish that we could hug each
and every one of you well
except for
and you know who you are
as you know every once in a while we
take in guests from around the
blogosphere the internet uh if you can
leave us a life's big question in the
reviews of the apple podcast review
section
uh we will get in touch with you and
bring you on the show
and we have found a delightful human
being who has a question for us today i
have no idea what this question is i
have not been prepped
but it looks like it's mackenzie smith
hi mckenzie how are you hi i'm great
guys how are you mackenzie smith does
not sound like a real name does that
sound like a real name to you it does
not sound like a real name you know what
it is you know what it reminds me of
it's like the name that you think of for
like a tertiary character and a script
yes like oh we got it we got to give
that we got to give the lady who owns
the dry cleaner a name what about
mackenzie smith
any truth to any of this speculation
mckenzie it's all true
i thought so mackenzie what is your
life's big question that is eating away
at you that you would love to bring to
us here at the metaphysical milkshake
stand so my question is why is the
meaning of life why do we as humans need
to ascribe meaning or is the meaning not
having a meaning at all and trying to
find the contentness of just being hmm
so why ask why basically is what you're
saying
exactly in other words what is the
purpose of this podcast
like really besides to make loads of
money loads of podcast money i think
there might be a false dichotomy in
there i don't know that someone
who truly ponders the meaning of
existence
is then unable to live in just a deep
appreciation
kind of stillness gratitude and
acceptance of what is i don't know that
those two things need to kind of be in
conflict
um
and i mean the dalai lama comes to mind
i mean i think it's someone who
ponders greatly the meaning of life and
why we're here and at the same time uh
isn't great peace um
i'm not sure if maybe i'm
misinterpreting your question a little
bit that's that's one thing and then the
other one it's like if you go back to
basics i've been thinking about this
question a lot recently like why is
there stuff
why is there anything instead of nothing
why isn't there just
nothing but instead there's
space time and matter
and energy is energy included in that
there's space-time matter and energy
all at the same time
and so why is there space-time matter
and energy all at the same time there
could just
be nothing but there is a bunch of
something
so
that is something that is a might seem
on its surface childish
but to me it's a pretty profound
question
and i guess the goal for me would be
can we live in quest of
meaning both in a universal context and
a personal context and at the same time
can we just
not drive ourselves crazy with it but
just accept and love what we have when
we have it well but that's see that's
really fascinating but i guess what
turns me on about mckenzie's question is
uh why are we compelled to do it
you know what i mean like why are we
why are we compelled to ask these kinds
of questions like evolutionarily
speaking
it's not helpful
right uh like if the whole notion is
about um you know the preservation of
the species and
about passing on you know um certain
uh aspects of your dna you know
generations after generation
truly the animal that that doesn't ask a
question when it sees the predator
coming is the one that survives right
the animal who's like
well yes but what does this predator
mean
and maybe i should you know ponder
the relationship that i have with nature
as this thing eats me uh
so it doesn't it doesn't seem like on
the surface that it would have like an
evolutionary advantage this sort of
questioning
of why right
but then again at the same time
part of
the growth of our brains
you know as we we've talked about this
before on the show like the brain is a
kind of muscle like you have to actually
exercise it right and and you can force
your brain to do things
uh by
focusing it in certain ways and
and
so maybe these kinds of questions these
unanswerable questions why
is a way of
expanding
certain parts of our brains right maybe
that's how we became at the top of the
food chain not because we learned how to
use a tool but because
we couldn't help but ask
why and the asking of the why expanded
our consciousness made us think about
things besides
the road right in front of us right the
nut or the food right in front of us
that's maybe that's the difference
between us and animals right is that
it's not about we have consciousness and
they don't we don't know that it's that
we take the time to ask why
and
they
don't right that there's there's a
question that we are interested in that
is beyond just this present moment back
to what you were saying mackenzie which
is like well but doesn't that keep us
from focusing on the present moment
maybe but maybe it's it's the ability to
move beyond the present moment that
makes us
who we are as human beings does that
make sense at all rain am i just talking
about my ass i mean yes but um does that
make sense at all we know each other
well enough to know that i entirely
agree with what you're saying right here
but i would love to throw back to
mackenzie have you have you struggled
with this kind of like battle between
like why are we here what is this as
opposed to like how can i just
enjoy my life and enjoy what i have
yeah i i definitely think i've always
kind of had that back and forth i've
always kind of you know
tried to think morphs essentially and i
would go down this whole rabbit hole
within myself but then at the same time
i can find that peace um and just being
and you know going outside and being in
nature and really enjoying being human
um but even with that it's like i still
ask myself like why like
wide everything honestly um and i really
love what reza said his point about you
know us as humans like maybe um talking
about like evolutionary wise and i think
that potentially you know we're
storytellers at heart and so we wouldn't
have gotten where we are today without
you know giving ourselves these ideas
like being able to make a fork being
able to make a boat being able to you
know create gods in our own minds
wow that's better than i said it i mean
right that was yeah our producer dj
lebel um put in the chat victor frankel
exclamation point to be helpful
and
at first i laughed and then i thought
you know what it really is helpful
because viktor frankl wrote his most
famous book is man's search for meaning
and as a holocaust survivor and a
concentration camp survivor
you know he witnessed firsthand
how people who had meaning
survived
uh unfathomable horrors
much better than those without meaning
if they had something to hold on to some
hope some strand
some thread that gave their life purpose
even if it was the pursuit of the
question why is this happening right
like why does why did why do bad things
happen to good people
that that see this is really interesting
rain because that's kind of what i was
uh
in my own mealy mouth way trying to say
earlier whereas that you have you have
two
beings and one is focused on like the
basic genetic instinct
to survive
so whether that's an animal
you know in the woods or that's a
hominid 200 000 years ago or whether
that's somebody trapped in a horrible
situation
uh like a concentration camp right put
your head down and survive basic genetic
instinct then you have this other being
who
is willing to go beyond that basic
instinct to a more
advanced
process right a more advanced cognitive
process
not just how do i get food right now but
why am i in the situation that i'm in
now what does it mean you know
how do i how do i understand the
universe
based on what i'm experiencing now and
as you
just pointed out and as frankl writes
that latter person
has a better chance of survival
than the former person who is focused on
the genetic instinct of i gotta get
through this day got to get through this
hour which is basically our animal
instinct right
so
in my non sort of scientific way that's
kind of what i was trying to say about
maybe the ques the
this ability to ask the question why
to go beyond the present moment and our
present needs and start to theorize
about the future moment and
theoretical needs
that that is the process whereby we did
survive whereby we we did become
you know the the top of the evolutionary
chain i love everything that said i
think at the end of the day you know we
kind of have to have both there has to
be a middle ground um i'm not saying you
know we should we should just stop
asking why and there's no meaning at all
but it is very interesting how i think
some of us can kind of overdo it and
always be thinking about the future
always be you know wondering like you
know what could have like what could be
different or you know why are we in the
place that we're in um instead of just
enjoying life um but as rosa said you
know we we do have to
i i think what sets us apart from
animals is the fact that we can kind of
like go this deep so i think just
finding the beauty in
our brains and buying of beauty and
nature
that's like maybe the key i love that
finding beauty um
we did an episode with my uncle rhett
diesener dr rhett diesner uncle rat who
studies beauty
and how beauty can be the focus of our
lives beauty in its largest context
truth beauty resonance in an
aristotelian way mackenzie thank you so
much you give our lives meaning
not you specifically you mackenzie smith
but
all of you listeners who all of you
mckenzie's all of the mckenzie's out
there listening pondering life's biggest
questions writing into us uh following
us on our socials and uh leaving a
terrific review for us on the apple
podcast uh review app and um
with your life's big question and we
would love to bring more mackenzie
smith's on the show to continue this
discussion thanks so much for uh joining
us mackenzie thanks mackenzie thanks so
much guys it's been awesome
well i'll tell you one thing
yeah i'm not afraid to face your death
oh
well thanks i i appreciate that i think
yeah i'm not i'm not afraid to face it
in fact i faced it and uh i did a little
task a little assignment i wrote your
obituary no it might happen later today
it might happen in two weeks or it might
happen in 27 years all right let's hear
this
reza aslan died the other day
he was hit by a bus while crossing the
street checking his twitter feed
it got messy believe me
he was best known for being an academic
a best-selling author a muslim mystic a
producer of television and film a
student of religion a provocateur slash
firebrand and a mediocre podcaster
but what you probably didn't know is
that mr aslan was the father of three
boys and was soon to be the father of a
daughter he was the best dad in the
world and he even took his wife and kids
around the world for a three-month tour
of the world's religions
along the way he put a lot of band-aids
on cuts let his wife sleep in while he
took the kids to the pool was always
ready with a juice box and a granola bar
when his sons were hungry and was in
charge of the luggage handling it is for
these actions that he will be most
greatly remembered in whatever heaven is
no one up there cares about all that
other [ __ ]
wow that was
that was kind of beautiful
yeah you like that
except for the bus part yeah
apropos of nothing i also just happened
to have also written your obituary what
you did you wrote one for me too
how did that happen i mean it's such a
crazy coincidence but i just i happened
i happen to have it right here
and you've got it right there okay great
i'd love to i'd love to hear what my
obituary sounds like
sounds like this
reign dietrich wilson's brain died in
his home today at the age of 152.
his body of course died decades earlier
in a horrible bassoon accident
and has been exhibited as a life-size
dwight schrute bobblehead
in the display window of nbc studios at
rockefeller center ever since
wilson's
wilson's brain is survived by his son
supreme commander walter mackenzie
wilson
and his wife holliday reinhorn and his
artificially intelligent sex robot wife
holiday 2.
perhaps best known as the voice of
gargamel in the 2017 animated smurfs
movie
now recognized as one of the most
influential films in american cinema
listed just below goodfellas in afi's
100
wilson enjoyed a middling career as a
film and television actor until he
achieved lasting fame for his brief
stint as reza aslan's sidekick on what
historians once referred to as a radio
podcast but which we now know more
simply as the ether
according to his loved ones his final
words before passing were quote
this is one doodle that can't be undid
home skillet though no one knows exactly
what the hell he was talking about
uh rain's former host the lord emperor
reza aslan said quote the world
is a quieter and darker place without
rain's face in it
that was pretty nice right
wow well done that is beautiful that is
that is
that is well done it's it's moving and
and also there's enough science fiction
elements in that that i would i would
want to watch that's kind of what i was
thinking about i was like yeah there's
there's a show where i am a former
middling television actor and my brain
is still alive and i have a sex robot
and there are weird commanders and i
want to see what the future looks like
in your imagination so listeners have
you ever written your own obituary i
suggest that you do do it do that write
an obituary for yourself what do you
hope that others would say about you
what would that look like
or or how about this or
take a picture of what you think your
deathbed will look like
and send that or draw draw your death
bad with what it looks like in your
imagination if you're not so much
writing about writing sentences and
you're a more visual person you can draw
your death bad either way face your
death we want to know about it send it
to us on twitter at reza aslan and at
rainwilson
metaphysical just don't do it while
you're crossing the street
with buses around write in tell us what
you think about this episode hashtag us
at metaphysical
so thanks again to our amazing guest
today alua arthur she was so
profound and beautiful and
simple and wise i got so much out of
this discussion we'll catch you next
week thanks for listening bye-bye
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold an audio mixed by justin
kyle original music by jeff tang
it was additionally executive produced
by goal reese lucina and daryush
rizwella no thaft it was produced by amy
estroy and rebecca lehrer of the mashup
americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowderwill
sarah pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby samuel
[Music]
i can hear your stomach gurgling in the
microphone that was my soul leaving my
body
it was it sounded like a burp pork and
vegetables kind of
thing my soul is mostly made of pork
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you